[Music]
on this Sunday night more retaliatory
action in the Middle East the US and UK
launch a new wave of strikes that this
was the beginning of our of our response
there will be more steps this time
targeting houthis in Yemen who are
demanding an end to the war in Gaza
Hockey Canada Scandal I also expect the
the police to address why the case was
reopened what to expect as the sexual
assault case involving five former world
junior hockey players begins in court on
Monday more protests in Alberta over the
province's proposed gender rights
changes and the game changer for tennis
players in frigid Quebec it's beyond my
Wildest
Dream global national with faren Asser
reporting tonight meu gcha good evening
and thanks for joining us the US is
escalating its invol involvement in the
Middle East in the past 48 Hours
Washington has launched two major
military operations against what it says
are Iran back
targets us officials say overnight with
help from the UK and support from Canada
it struck 36 houthi Targets in Yemen it
is retaliation for the rebel groups
attacks on shipping vessels in the Red
Sea which the houthi say are in
solidarity with the people of Gaza the
latest strikes follow us attacks inside
Iraq and Syria on Friday night a direct
response for a drone attack that killed
three US soldiers in Jordan a week ago
Washington has stopped short of calling
the escalation a war but is promising
further action and the houthi rebel
group also says the US attacks will not
go unpunished Redmond Shannon has our
top story
tonight footage provided by the US
military shows B1 bombers leaving Texas
on Saturday Bound for
Yemen British typhoon Jets head for the
same destination their mission supported
by six countries including Canada
targeted houthi sites in locations
across Yemen the third such joint
operation in a month carried out in
response to the iran-backed militant
groups strikes against Merchant shipping
in the Red Sea a campaign that began in
nov November in solidarity with the
people of
Gaza the group said Sunday it won't be
deterred by the bombing and that it will
respond this houie official says the
yemeni people will continue to prepare
for the confrontation with the American
and British
enemy ominous words suggesting a
spiraling conflict are not confined to
Yemen we have to be clear right about
that the White House National Security
advisor says the us is not done with its
campaign against Iran back militants in
Syria and Iraq following us air strikes
against them on Friday they were carried
out in response to the killing of three
US troops in Jordan last weekend Jake
Sullivan declined to say if strikes were
planned for inside Iran too that this
was the beginning of our of our response
there will be more steps some of those
steps will be seen some may not be seen
in Baghdad funerals for me of a Shia
armed group killed in the US strikes
it's technically part of Iraq's Army but
backed by
Iran this Shia leader says it's time for
Iraq to kick out the 2500 US troops
still stationed in the country they're
there as part of a coalition fighting
against what is a common enemy in the
region Islamic
State the prospect of more US air
strikes in Iraq adds to the pressure on
prime minister Muhammad Al Sudani who
began negotiations on a US withdrawal
last week Redman Shannon Global News
London the US Secretary of State Anthony
blinkin is on the way to the region to
push for a ceasefire between Israel and
Hamas blinkin will be part of truce
talks this week mediated by the US qar
and Egypt nearly four months into the
conflict there is still constant
fighting in Gaza City in the densely
populated enclaves North and in Han UN
in the South and Israel is expanding its
offensive around Rafa near the Egyptian
border displaced Palestinians are
Sheltering wherever they can including
in destroyed buildings the Hamas run
Health Ministry says more than 27,000
people have been killed since the
fighting erupted the war in Ukraine
shows no end in sight but Ukraine is
slowly clawing back around overnight 28
people were killed by shelling that hit
a bakery in a town located in the
luhansk region in eastern Ukraine
Ukraine's defense Ministry has not
commented on the attack but the town was
taken by Russian forces in July of 2022
and Ukraine has been wrapping up attacks
on Russian controlled territory as its
ground offensive stalls and today
Ukraine's President Vladimir zalinski
visited troops in a Southern Frontline
Village that keev retook from Russia
last summer a high-profile investigation
into du allegations of sexual assault
involving players from Canada's 2018
World Junior hockey team goes to court
tomorrow five hockey players four of
them in the NHL and one former nhlr now
playing in Europe are facing charges
they sexually assaulted a woman in a
London Ontario hotel room 6 years ago
all five men are expected to plead not
guilty Eric senson reports from London
Ontario
tonight it is potentially a watershed
moment for hockey and the justice system
in this country on Monday police in
London will outline line long delayed
charges of sexual assault for five
professional hockey players on leave
from their teams including three NHL
clubs careers and reputations hang in
the balance they're in unknown territory
I mean their careers are at stake their
professional life is at stake you know
their uh their ability to earn a living
you know they could be incarcerated as
well for the accuser identified as em it
is an agonizing Quest For Justice this
is going to be a brutal brutal
experience for her dapan Gilbert says
complainants have often faced a backlash
when celebrities like sports heroes are
accused but she says police and
prosecutors are acutely aware of the
enormous public interest in this case it
does seem to have taken a long time and
I can only hope that that means that the
case is really solid now that it's
coming forward Gilbert says the case
will hinge on consent applied distinctly
to each of the accused the alleged
assault is said to have happened in this
London hotel after a hockey Canada Gala
in June 2018 honoring the world junior
Champions the five accused played for
that that celebrated team the woman was
20 at the time the whole legal system in
Canada is not well suited uh to
assisting sexual assault survivors
Macintosh Ross says the case will test
not just the legal system but other
institutions such as Hockey Canada which
quietly paid a settlement to the accuser
while the accused kept playing in the
NHL and Europe there will have to be a
commitment from the NHL from Hockey
Canada uh from lawyers
journalists um players coaches is to
really make a commitment to changing
this culture because this didn't happen
overnight this happened over decades I
think any characterization that this is
a systemic issue is both inaccurate and
unfair the NHL's commissioner felt
compelled to answer critics as the
League's all-star weekend was showcasing
its best players Gary bman distanced the
NHL from those now facing charges all
will be free agents at the end of this
season though bman wouldn't say what the
League's plans are are what transpires
in the judicial proceedings may have to
may have to some extent an impact on
what we choose to do for not do for now
the players hockey careers are on hold
as they face criminal charges in this
courthouse on Monday the charges haven't
been tested in court lawyers for the
players say they will plead not guilty
Eric senson Global News London
Ontario there were protests again today
from those opposed to policy proposals
in Alberta taking aim at transgender
rights the province's premier says she
believes her government is striking the
right balance when it comes to kids but
criticism across Canada has been Swift
as Heather urx West explains the push
back could have political implications
Beyond Danielle Smith and her United
conservative
party sweeping proposed changes to
transgender rights in Alberta brought
out protesters once again on Sunday to
the steps of Edmonton's legislature you
are safe and you are loved and outside
of Alberta as well this was the scene in
New Brunswick as the province's
controversial policy makes waves
Nationwide this
potentially pushes this issue this set
of issues onto the federal agenda in a
way that might be difficult for the the
federal conservatives federally liberal
and NDP members were quick to denounce
The Proposal but there may be concerns
among some federal conservatives too MP
Greg mlan who represents Calgary Center
says he's been speaking to his lgbtq2
constituents and that as proposed
Alberta's policy may need to be modified
and I have spoken to the premier's
office about this and I'll be speaking
more about the pathways we have here
going forward so that we're actually
talking to the people there are some of
Canada's most marginalized people and
making sure we have solutions for the
parents everywhere within Alberta of
politics this issue could bring nahed n
back into public life we protect
everyone we protect every kid and we
protect them right
now in a statement to Global News nchi
says he's now considering entering the
race to lead the provincial NDP I have
been listening to a lot of pitches from
party members and other albertans over
the coming weeks I hope to have more
conversations about whether my running
would help build build a better Alberta
in terms of his potential success I
think it's very interesting because he
is of course the mayor the former mayor
of Calgary and although the NDP did make
inroads in Calgary in the last election
with nchi they could conceivably take
more seats in calary in gender
reassignments but an election in Alberta
is more than 3 years away and Alberta's
Premier believes her proposal has broad
voter
support even as those against the PO
policy make their opposition known
Heather urx West Global News Calgary
across Nova Scotia today people are
being asked to hunker down as a winter
storm pounds The
Province up to 80 cm of snow has fallen
in some places this weekend in Halifax
residents are being told to avoid
non-essential travel transit services
cautiously resumed around noon today
after being halted this morning airport
services were also Limited with many
flights canceled or delayed cap Breton
Regional municipality has also declared
a local state of
emergency the reason that Council
decided to go forward with the local
state of emergency is really and truly
to keep people off the roads we need to
keep people in their houses because
right now in your home is the safest
place where where you can be the local
state of emergency is in place for seven
days Global News meteorologist Ivon
shell joins me now with the Outlook
Yvonne
neia we continue to track a significant
amount of snow along the east coast and
it's been a prolonged period of snow
that will give us additional amounts now
the areas in Nova Scotia that will be a
concern with the snowfall warning still
seeing 10 and up to 20 cm these are
additional amounts and even higher
amounts towards the Eastern regions Cape
Bron with the winter storm warning with
up to 25 cmers another concern as we get
in this evening and continuing in
towards tomorrow is blowing snow near
zero visibility with some of the Winds
with gusts between 70 and up to 80 kilm
per hour so snowfall will continue
overnight by tomorrow afternoon should
taper off to a chance for some flurries
for most areas it'll give us a nice
break between systems by Tuesday we're
seeing cloud cover and the return for
some sunshine by our Wednesday Neu
thanks
Ivon damage from deadly forest fires
coming up the destruction as towering
Flames claim dozens of lives in
Chile in Chile there are scenes of
Devastation as deadly wildfires tear
through the country's valpariso region
the blazes have destroyed more than a
thousand homes killing at least 99
people hundreds remain missing the
country's president warns the death toll
is expected to rise even further Abigail
Bean has more on the destruction and the
uphill battle
ahead fighting fires from the air and
the
ground it was like living through hell
says this woman who lost her home in the
coastal tourist city of V
delmare we need help this woman says
Food Supplies clothes I lost
everything this tailor couple tries to
salvage what's left of a
workshop well these people search for a
missing cat areas near Vina delmare and
B pariso have been hardest hit home to
around a million people and about 120
kilm from the capital Santiago at least
1200 homes destroyed and 9,000 hectar
burned the fires broke out during a heat
wave in central
Chile weather has made extinguishing as
many as 90 fires more challenging with
high winds low humidity and temperatures
topping
40° authorities are also investigating
whether arson played a role this is the
deadliest catastrophe since the 2010
earthquake that killed 500
people and Chile's president said Sunday
the death toll will rise
significantly Crews work around the
clock to not only battle active blazes
but help the injured and find the
missing in his weekly address Pope
Francis prayed for the dead and injured
in the fires he called
devastating a state of emergency was
declared Friday night while the
president announced two days of national
mour will start Monday Abigail ban
global news
Ottawa in the US California is facing
more heavy rains from a second
atmospheric River in less than a
week millions of people in the state
will be under flood watches for the next
few days around Los Angeles and Santa
Barbara forecasters are warning of
life-threatening flash flooding and
mudslides some places expect up to 30 cm
of rain there are also warnings of
hurricane force winds including the
possibility of brief
tornadoes ahead opponents of the planned
Quebec EV battery plant in protest what
action they're calling for
[Music]
next there was a protest today against a
planned $7 billion EV battery plant in
Quebec over fears it will leave a large
footprint on a wetland near Montreal a
coalition of several environmental
groups has demanded a full environmental
study of the project by Swedish
manufacturer northvolt an injunction in
court had temporarily halted earlier
preparations but they've now resumed as
worries rise between locals and
environmental activist Elizabeth zalis
reports the company had started felling
trees on its 170 hectar site but it
stopped in mid January after an
injunction request was filed by
environmental groups and citizens
there's no public transparency there's
no information for people that are
available so this project is definitely
on a fast track while we should have
like proper moment to think about it
have the information ask question get
answers two weeks ago a judge ruled
North po could continue construction
Sunday's demonstration nicknamed a
funeral walk was to shed light on the
environmental damage and loss that will
occur when shovels are in the ground a
lot of people a lot of groups are asking
for a proper independent assessment of
this project because the government has
been bulldozing this project Patrick
Bonet with Greenpeace Canada says the
government is finding loopholes to fast
track the project the government did
change the rules making sure that this
project wouldn't go under the the B the
Bure on
environment residents are concerned this
will set a precedent and open the door
to more largescale industrial projects
without them being subjected to all the
necessary environmental assessments all
the wetlands this is one of them it's
not a big one but there are many more
which will be affected down the line cuz
many more plants will be coming many
more mines will be opened up much more
of our land will be
damaged demonstrators unanimously agree
a project of this scale needs to be
fully evaluated when you put in billions
of dollars and you create a huge space
and you change the social fabric of the
area you do it carefully and slowly
using a lot of people to reflect on the
best way to do it northv claims it will
make the greenest batteries in the world
in Quebec and bring thousands of jobs on
Friday it announced it wants to create a
community liaison committee Elizabeth
zalis Global News mcmasterville
next the court covering change Quebec
tennis players say is beyond their
Wildest
Dreams it is official Canada's quest to
win the 2026 FIFA World Cup will begin
in Toronto [__] Field gets set to host
six games during the tournament while
Vancouver's BC Place will host seven
including two of Team Canada's matches
the biggest ever edition of the World
Cup kicks off in Mexico City while
finals will be in New Jersey Canadians
are well known for hitting the ice or
the slopes this time of year but now a
traditional summer sport is becoming a
smash hit this winter tennis played
under inflatable domes tennis Canada is
sanctioning the sport under these
bubbles to encourage more people to pick
up the game in the cooler months as Tim
Sergeant reports players are swinging
into
it Jean pelan is really getting into the
swing of playing under a dome this is
obviously a great great asset for us the
player says hitting balls inside an
inflatable bubble is a game changer the
more the better I mean uh people will be
able to keep on playing year
round waterl in the Eastern Township of
Quebec is one of the latest places where
outdoor courts have been temporarily
transformed into an indoor facility
covered by a dome that's removable come
spring we're actually standing on
outdoor for these are exterior cours
yeah that's right yeah Canadian tennis
Legend Fran GBU helped pay for the $1.6
million structure after being approached
was that Mine by the local Pro Who
convinced tennis Canada corporate
sponsors and the City of watero to chip
in it's beyond my wildest dreams I tell
you Norman Roth Jing first had the idea
more than a decade ago his plan make
tennis more affordable by charging
players a fraction of the cost of
joining an indoor Club several
inflatable domes sanctioned by tennis
Canada already exist across the country
most notably in the provinces of Ontario
and
Alberta this is the only one in Quebec
it's a partnership between a nonprofit
and the city so our overhead is very low
and therefore we could charge the
players less
the goal of tennis Canada is to have 30
of these domes by 2030 to cover 160
courts and open up tennis a lot more to
the recreational player so we try to
find ways that playing all year round
doesn't cost so much and and that's our
mission we're trying to get more people
on the
courts Simon Roth Jing trains here and
loves it it looks cool I like it a lot
because I don't know I've would been in
a place like this the dome is also
opening up opportunities to hundreds of
young players who normally would never
pick up a racket in the winter we have
three schools here that could walk here
about 1,500 students locally making sure
players of all
ages get a big hit inside a bubble
that's inflating in popularity Tim
Sergeant Global News waterl Quebec yeah
fun for all ages that is global national
for this Sunday night I'm Neu garcha
tonight's your candida is Dead Man's
Cove Beach in Harbor Breton New Finland
and Labrador we love seeing your Canada
please keep emailing your photos to
viewers at Global national.com thanks so
much for watching Donna will be back
with you tomorrow have a great
night